oh yesterday it was announced that alex
trebek lost
the battle with pancreatic cancer he
died at age 80.
wasn't he just hosting he was hosting
for a while because he found out he had
cancer he said that he was still gonna
do the show while he can and it got to a
point where he couldn't do it anymore so
he stopped
damn and then he was trying to fight it
i think he
got pancreatic cancer twice i think he
beat it the first time and then the
second time he got it
there was only a seven percent chance of
himself the diagnosis if it's like
stage like station number four
pancreatic cancer yeah my girl's grandma
had
its game set match there was really
nothing to do for it what yeah yeah yeah
pancreatic cancer is [ __ ] awful man
so that's so when someone gets that it's
like yo it's only
yeah it's more about like a few worst
places but pancreatic is probably the
worst
what's this video him signing off i
don't know what this video is play it
i won't stop fighting oh no that was
when you initially
this is when you revealed it to the
world if you've got a minute i'd like to
bring you up to date on my health
situation i love his voice
the one-year survival rate for stage
four
pancreatic cancer patients is 18
i'm very happy to report i have just
reached that marker
now i'd be lying if i said the journey
had been an easy one
there were some good days but a lot of
not so good days
i joked with friends that the cancer
won't kill me the chemo treatments will
hurt chemotherapy yeah days when certain
bodily functions
no longer functioned and sudden massive
attacks of great depression
that made me wonder if it really was
worth fighting on
but i brushed that aside quickly because
that would have been a massive betrayal
a betrayal of my wife and soulmate gene
who has given her all
to help me survive it would have been a
betrayal of other cancer patients
who have looked to me as an inspiration
and a cheerleader of sorts of the value
of living and hope
and it would certainly have been a
betrayal of my faith in god
and the millions of prayers that have
been said on my behalf
you know my oncologist tried to cheer me
up the other day he said
alex even though the two-year survival
rate is only seven percent
he was certain that one year from now
the two of us would be sitting in his
office
celebrating my second anniversary of
survival
and you know something if i no
if we because so many of us are involved
in this same situation
if we take it just one day at a time
with a positive attitude
anything is possible i'll keep you
posted
have you ever seen the contestants like
the one guy yeah
do you see the one guy from india won
give me chills he won
and uh he's like anything you want to
say and he's like i learned
english yeah he said he learned english
he's still watching with his grandpa
that was on complex if y'all want to
watch that they posted that and there's
also another one a guy won and he was
like
oh no he knew he was going to lose and
he was like i just want to say he's like
we heart you yeah yeah we love you alex
man shout out to this uh queen g wait
is that who is that the other took the
fight no it just said that chandler's
not going to do the fight
yeah as you you already said oh
man right there right there
right here oh this part's great what is
we love you out that's very kind
thank you costco
19.95 you're left with five bucks
okay did you come up with the new
champion twenty thousand
four hundred for bert packer any family
he tax that
back home uh you know here's a true
story man
this is great i learned english because
of you and so
my grandfather who raised me i'm going
to get tears right now he
we i used to sit on his lap and watch
you every day so
it's a pretty special moment for me man
thank you very much
[Music]
did they find like a new host or
something or man i'm talking about dude
cause they said he stopped doing it i
didn't know if they were like still
showing up
you know you know that little dumbass
that uh the political
dude he's from uh good morning america
he like put his name on
van jones i forget oh no i don't know i
forget it's like damn dog
what happened the body's barely cold you
already auditioned for the [ __ ] role
of jeopardy
think of someone else i didn't know my
agents have a reach out to me
let's ask me a heavy crown of you know
oh 100
yeah and you know this is this is kind
of controversial but i think
if if you have you guys ever known
anyone that died from cancer
oh yeah probably you for sure so like
the whole chemo thing is such a tricky
thing
i think looking back my go ahead no
looking back at one of my friends that
passed away recently oh that's right
i feel like if we didn't do the k or
they didn't do the chemo
he would he might have lived longer and
happier dude peep this so my uncle pax
got uh throat cancer started hitting the
body on the tongue in his throat
went through chemo beat it and we were
like oh yeah
he lost all taste his teeth fell out he
was felt horrible the the the cancer
came back and like right another set of
chemo he's like nope
that was worse than anything cancer can
do they say they're gonna look back on
like 20 years what
like what chemo did to people and i'm
like what the [ __ ]
i mean yeah that's what i'm saying like
how how chemo just doesn't
just doesn't go for the cancer cells it
kills everything dude
that's the reason why you lose your hair
it's not because of the cancer it kills
it kills themselves yeah it does it just
doesn't you know distinguish between
cancer and regular it kills [ __ ]
everything
damn so hopefully they find you know
other ways to deal with it yeah i wish
i hope so my stomach hurt what what
not because i hear stuff like that yeah
it's soft chemo
yeah no it's just like his stomach like
it makes his stomach hurt like
it's like not yeah sad like i turn it on
yeah that's sad
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son